we just moments ago heard britney
spears's testimony i know we were both
listening to it were you in the
courtroom or were you outside
what was happening in the courtroom
itself were gasps
of being elicited what was it like you
know i was in the front row so it was
hard to see people behind
me but they actually for the first time
had a zoom so you could see
people brittany was just on her phone so
you couldn't see her but it was
interesting to watch all the lawyers
faces as she was
saying this and it looked like everyone
was trying to have a very
expressionless face but it was
definitely dramatic
and i think you know when she first said
like this is abusive
and you know she really talked about a
lot of stuff that in our
investigation it backs up exactly what
she's saying and
you know at one point she said i didn't
i haven't said anything publicly because
i didn't think anyone would believe me
and we i mean we believe her but also we
have
records to show that she's telling the
truth of what happened
so i mean we kind of heard her own
lawyer
when he was given the chance to respond
he seemed shocked by what she had said
what were the looks you were seeing on
the lawyer's faces and could you see her
parents at all
no her parents were both on just audio
but i think
you know one of the first things she
said was
i didn't know i was i was able to file a
petition to end it
so i imagine her lawyer would have a
reaction
to that since he's the one who is
supposed to communicate to her that she
could do that
we know from all these records that she
has
expressed that she wants it to end so
many times
and the idea that now 13 years later she
doesn't know
she could file a petition that is a
failure in the court system
that was that felt like a massive
bombshell to me because
we have seen time and time again in the
press that allegedly well she could end
at any time
so did that feel shocking to you and
what else stood out to you as
those oh my gosh moments you know i
think that
with with this whole conservatorship
case the
silence has really
silence has made it so it seems like
britney
is consenting to this and when when you
know
finally she was able to speak given the
opportunity she said thank you for this
opportunity she should have known that
she had this opportunity the whole time
and she says every you know everything
that
we found in the documents but that
people have been thinking and even
stronger she said i feel
like this has been abusive she said i
feel like people should go to jail for
this
she said i've i'm working and making
all this money and i'm also working and
making all these people's incomes as
soon as that started happening
the conservatorship should have been
over like it's clear i don't
i shouldn't be in this and
she also said that things like that she
wanted to get married
and have a baby but that she had an iud
in and she said that they she felt like
they wouldn't take her to the doctor to
get it taken out
when you were hearing these things did
you expect that level of control
or even knowing all the background you
know did you still find some of it
shocking
honestly i didn't i expected all that
yeah i wasn't i didn't know she was
going to say all of that
but it's so it was thrilling to
be able to actually hear it from her
voice and and how she feels about it you
know she was very passionate that it
should end
and that she had been wronged and abused
she also said her management
she felt forced by her management to
perform and go on tours and that she
would be punished if she didn't she
mentioned
visits with her kids and her boyfriend
could be taken away it was shocking to
me that she said
i want to sue my whole family i wondered
does she include her mom and that does
she include her sister in that what's
your take on that
you know my my suspicion is that
since she's you know controlled by so
many people outside of her family
there's
when you look at the zoom and there's
all these lawyers lined up and then
britney is this little like audio bubble
on the side it was it was very visually
striking and i think
yeah she has a whole management team she
has all these doctors and lawyers and
her father
and i think that they're able to she
said herself
i feel so alone i don't want to feel
alone anymore
and i think my suspicion is that she's
been kept from so many people
in her family besides her father that it
you know she feels alone so no matter no
matter
what her family is doing she feels alone
for whatever circumstances
i was very struck by because to be
honest the world i think is questioned
britney's mental state we have because
of her social media and all these things
and i was just struck by how lucid how
confident she was
i loved hearing her say that she's not
just good at her job she's great
what was your emotional reaction when
you were hearing some of that i mean
you know we know from a transcript that
she had said she had told the court in
2019 there is nothing wrong with me
she also said today she said you know i
told you all this to the judge i told
you all this in two years ago
and after after i did that i felt dead
and i felt like i she said i felt
dead and and something to the extent of
and i felt
like ignored because i was ignored you
know i remember she i felt dead but it
was something else also
because she was making the point that
she felt like she said this and no one
no one did anything or listened to her
like like she didn't exist is what she
was
saying it was incredibly striking and i
wonder
you know how this feels for you i know
you're interviewing some of the fans
you've interviewed for the documentary
how does just this moment feel for you
and what do you want to do in terms of
the next step for your coverage of all
this
yeah i mean as a journalist listening to
that i felt
you know we we have you talk to a lot of
people and find out a lot of stuff out
and you have all these theories but
there's like that one moment where what
you think is happening
is and it's it there's it's proof that
it's happening and so today
i got the proof that it's happening what
do you think's happening with her social
media because
there was that comment that you know
i i don't know it's hard because i i i
do not think her social media is her
after hearing that because it sounds
nothing like what i heard today and what
i heard today was the real britney
spears
so i mean to be when i'm hearing she's
saying i felt demoralized
i'm like this is it it was striking i
don't know
it was striking so it was heartbreaking
but i guess my one word for today would
be revelation
like it felt like you know everything
was opened up